et la parole est à monsieur pierre
lellouche eh bien monsieur le premier
ministre
1 la grèce toujours et cette question
s'adresse à vous parce que je vous avoue
ne pas très bien comprendre où on va en
écoutant monsieur sapin plusieurs
reprises aujourd'hui
commençons par le commencement
tout le monde ici monsieur le premier
ministre diby à tout le monde veut que
la grèce reste dans l'union européenne
et dans la zone euro et personnes
personne ne souhaite
une faillite qui serait catastrophique
pour son pour son peuple
mais enfin trop c'est trop voilà six
mois que tsipras ce fait de la politique
intérieure avec l'argent des autres
c'est à dire l'argent des contribuables
européens qu'ils m'en sens propre peuple
qu'il ment à ses créanciers
et en plus ils nous couvrent d'injures
pardonnez-moi face à ses mains face à
ces manoeuvres
vous n'avez cessé vous et françois
hollande de financer de finasser parce
que évidemment qui prince il est soutenu
on l'a entendu tout à l'heure par une
partie de votre majorité
alors tentons soutien de six traces
tantôt on rappelle les règles de la zone
euro au final c'est illisible et là
monsieur sa parodie mais il reste encore
quelques heures
m'enfin je vous rappelle que lors du
quinquennat précédent
la france avait apporté 40 milliards
dette directe nous étions à les
emprunter pour les prêter aux grecs
c'est à dire deux points de pipe c'est
les pousser il ya des dons ont été
apportées à la grecque
rien que par le cieutat c'est sans
parler du fmi
combien de temps allez-vous continuer à
supplier de sipera ce de bien vouloir
prendre notre argent
c'est ça la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui est quel est le plan b du
gouvernement
s'il vous plaît monsieur sapin un vote
compte c'est pas votre wii
en effet monsieur sapin un vote contre
et pamba puisque tsipras ce voeu que la
grèce votre compte
au risque de haut risque de mourir la
grèce dit qu'elle veut faire sauter la
zone euro qu'allez vous faire
quel est votre plan b dans ce cas et
quelle est la convergence franco
allemand pour sauver la zone euro
problème qui se posera dès lundi
prochain la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre manuel valls sur le
président s'il vous plaît on écoute la
radio
lellouche je ne sais pas si monsieur
cipra ce fait de la politique intérieure
sans doute mais honnêtement j'ai
l'impression que vous en faites un tout
petit peu à travers votre question
nous avons un devoir en tout cas pour
ceux qui gouvernent parce que il faut le
constater vous les de le faire
d'ailleurs avec des arguments
particulièrement pertinents la situation
grecque n'était pas réglée elle n'était
pas réglée avant même d'ailleurs
l'élection d'un nouveau gouvernement
et c'est peut-être pour cela que
monsieur si price a eu une majorité au
parlement grec
parce que les problèmes de la grèce
n'était pas réglée et nous le savons
nous le rappelions avec michel sapin il
ya encore un instant la grèce doit
s'engager dans les réformes
en tenant compte de ce que le peuple
grec a subi ce que le peuple grec a subi
attendons le résultat de dimanche
mais en attendant nous devons tout faire
tout faire pour trouver une solution et
ce n'est pas seulement monsieur
lellouche
la position de la france hier avec
souvent les mêmes mots et n'essayez pas
d'opposer parce que je ne pense pas que
ce soit d'ailleurs de bonnes politiques
et je ne pense pas que ce soit utile
d'opposer le président de la république
et la chancelière d'allemagne avec les
mémos chacun s'est déclaré disponible
pour trouver une solution aujourd'hui et
y compris pour trouver une solution la
semaine prochaine après le référendum et
après l'expression souveraine du peuple
grec qui doit pouvoir s'exprimer en
toute connaissance de cause et c'est ce
que nous faisons
le gouvernement français le président de
la république le président de la
commission encore aujourd'hui la
chancelière merkel hier avec à ses côtés
le vice chancelier sigmar gabriel parce
que chacun monsieur lellouche doit être
bien conscient de la responsabilité qui
est la nôtre
la sortie de la grèce de la zone euro
après le vote du peuple grec serait un
drame d'abord pour la grèce d'abord pour
les grecs
d'abord pour son économie avec des
conséquences nous les connaissons pas
tout
nous savons que la france est robuste
nous savons que la crise aujourd'hui
n'est pas tout à fait la même que celle
que le connaissions il y a quatre ans
mais avec des conséquences politiques
avaient des conséquences politiques
majeurs pour l'idée que nous nous
faisons de l'europe alors la position du
président la république du gouvernement
exprimé par le ministre des finances est
clair
souhaitons et nous voulons pas à
n'importe quelle condition bien
évidemment c'est le sens de la
discussion et de la négociation mais que
la grèce reste dans la zone euro parce
que c'est essentiel pour l'avenir de
l'europe
c'est la position du gouvernement
français elle est clair ça n'est pas
seulement monsieur lellouche
la position du gouvernement français
parce que chaque responsable européen
doit être mis devant ses responsabilités
c'est aussi l'avenir de l'europe qui est
en cause